steeped in spirituality politics and
conflict the dalai lama faces a dilemma
and it's all to do with his successor
when he dies dalai lama is caught
between the two great powers of of
southern and eastern asia he's renowned
for his non-violent commitment to
freeing tibet we
seeking genuine autonomy not seeking
independence and his sense of humor
but who actually is the dalai lama
tibet and buddhist believe the dalai
lama has existed for around 600 years
the first being born in 1391 he's
believed to be a living buddha who is
reincarnated after death this is the
14th and current dalai lama tenzin
gyatso he was identified as the
reincarnation of the 13th dalai lama
when he was just two years old he turned
87 in 2022
and is a global figure a good friend
his holiness the dalai lama
who is a powerful example of what it
means to practice compassion he's been
committed to tibet's liberation since he
fled to dharamasala in india's himalayan
foothills where he still lives today
so why was he forced to flee
in 1949 mao zedong came to power in
china he claimed tibet was part of china
and invaded
the tibetans eventually surrendered and
were forced to accept china's
sovereignty the dalai lama aged just 15
along with about 80 000 other tibetans
fled to india where they and their
descendants have been ever since the
chinese view the dalai lama as someone
very dangerous because of his
international connections his
credibility as a religious leader but
they also view buddhism and all
religions now as dangerous
so china has a vested interest in who
the dalai lama's successor will be and
it's trying to control the outcome
traditionally when the dalai lama dies
there's a search for a child
reincarnation and when they're chosen
they have to study in preparation for
their role the panchayat lama is the
second most important figure in tibetan
buddhism after the dalai lama and they
play a key role in choosing the next
leader
in 1995 the current dalai lama chose one
but china rejected the choice and
kidnapped the six-year-old they then
chose their own gyan
who lives in tibet the chinese are
certain to demand control of the choice
of the dalai lama's successor if that
success is born in india the chinese are
going to do everything in their powers
to prevent india from recognizing the
next dalai lama and this will lead to
dramatically increased tensions between
india and china
the dalai lama hasn't set out a clear
succession plan but in 2011 set out
three possibilities for his successor
first is the traditional way of choosing
a child reincarnation after his death
but this isn't without its problems if
you use that system you choose a child
it takes many years to find that child
there's often disputes over that child
whether it's the right one and then
you've got to rate another 15 years for
the child to grow up second is a child
being chosen before the dalai lama dies
and finally there's the possibility of
an adult being appointed before he dies
he warned no recognition should be given
to any candidate chosen for political
ends by anyone including agents of china
the dalai lama also retired from
politics in 2011. ending a 368 year old
tradition everybody thought it was a
sign of his commitment to democracy but
actually it was much more than that
because he
he removed any future dalai lamas from
having a political role but there's
another aspect which got missed i think
it was a signal to the chinese that he
was ready and willing to negotiate with
them because he now no longer has an
official political position
when the dalai lama dies the biggest
fight could be over his succession and
we could see a scenario where two dalai
lamas are appointed the chinese will say
that only they have the right to choose
the next dalai lama and the exiles will
almost certainly choose their own
success into the dalai lama then there's
the scenario where tibet could be locked
down
chinese are already preparing for they
already have cadres in every village in
tibet and they are opening police
stations in every collision and finally
there's the question of the exile
tibetan government in dara masala and
whether india will still want to host
the exiles after the dalai lama has died
we're looking at a very high stakes
gamble that the dalai lama is playing
has been trying to play for the last 30
years which is to offer to negotiate
with the chinese in the hope that they
will take a moderate view
and give some concessions to his demand
for more cultural religious autonomy in
tibet
whether he can get that agreement from
them before he dies it looks very
unlikely there's no signs of chinese
concession china is getting more
aggressive internally as well as
externally but still the dalai lama is
hoping that might happen
you